begin with this boxes were huge massive
breaking developments tonight in our
quest for equal justice and the truth
our own John Solomon House Republicans
are now considering filing criminal
referrals against Muller prosecutors now
this is major news John Solomon will be
here he will break it all down tonight
but first we begin the president making
history in the world's biggest democracy
just a few hours ago he landed in New
Delhi India where a hundred thousand
plus locals were lined up along the
president's motorcade rote route and
another hundred plus thousands filling
India's largest cricket arena 110 or
20,000 where the president delivered a
rousing speech vowing that America will
always be faithful to loyal friends like
the Indian people and we'll have much
more on this coming up later in the
program but now let's turn our attention
back home where we have a busy weekend
to unpack bolshevik Bernie Sanders is
now the unquestioned undisputed without
a doubt clear front-runner in the
Democratic primary on Saturday he won
the Nevada caucus by whopping 26 points
he now has a major head of steam and
momentum rolling into this coming
Saturday South Carolina's primary and
then one week from tomorrow Super
Tuesday which takes place well all the
world to see this is now game time and
this is when they get the meanest in the
next several days buckle up we're about
to witness what will be a bare-knuckles
political brawl inside the Democratic
Party figuratively speaking the knives
are out for Bolshevik Bernie and others
and already by the way it's not a pretty
sight as you all know I always tell you
every two years every four years
what's the Democratic playbook against
Republicans always centers around
identity politics Republicans a racist
sexist misogynist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic it want dirty air water
they want Grandma and Grandpa eat dog
food and cat food and let's see a Kevin
McCarthy or Donald Trump look-alike will
throw granny over the cliff pretty
predictable but before they get to run
those phony ads well they get to do to
each other what they do to Republicans
every two and four years and that is now
a total shift show political knife fight
and it's only getting started
Bolshevik Bernie now facing scrutiny
centered around a truly disturbing
pretty vile sick ugly article that he
wrote himself in 1972 we do have a
viewer warning about this what I am
about to show you is well beyond creepy
and beyond graphic and a piece entitled
man and women Sanders writes about
various quote rape fantasies one section
writing quote a woman enjoys intercourse
with her man as she's fantasizing about
being raped by three men simultaneously
move over creepy Joe and former Mayor
Bloomberg in other words and another
paragraph he writes quote you know why
the newspaper with articles like girl 12
raped by 14 men sell so well - what in
US are they appealing he writes
bolshevik speak for yourself beyond
gross weird repulsive that's frankly a
level I can't comprehend and of course
Sanders and his campaign are disavowing
the articles even though he wrote it
calling it decades-old attempt at dark
satire now this might be the least by
the way of Bernie Bolsheviks worries is
by calling himself a democratic
socialist Bolshevik Bernie Sanders spent
decades piling around with some of the
most vile evil murderous socialist
regimes the world has ever seen
look at this 1988 what a wonderful
honeymoon took his wife ten-day
honeymoon the former Soviet Union where
he praised their infrastructure and
their youth programs whoo honeymoons in
the former Soviet Union the former
Soviet you forget about the hostile
actor that is Vladimir Putin and he's
hostile or the hostile regime that is
Russia they're hostile the communist
system in the Soviet Union was a special
level of evil in and of itself
now the Bolshevik Bernie forget the tens
of millions of political dissidents were
murdered by the very same Soviet
government where he's honeymooning at
the time did he forget about the gulags
did he forget about the KGB terrorizing
the entire population did he forget that
millions more died from starvation they
forget about the bread lines because
that was a way of life in the former
Soviet Union waiting on line for basic
necessities Oh milk wheat bread medical
supplies all in
supply families were packed into tiny
poorly maintained government housing and
that nearly everyone there lived in
abject poverty and fear except of course
for the leaders themselves is that
Bernie socialist utopia one notable
Russian author a political prisoner
wrote all communist parties upon
obtaining power have become completely
merciless and but at the stage before
they achieve power it is necessary to
use disguises well said
so there's Bolshevik Bernie really that
stupid for all these disguises because
by the way he just didn't praise the
Soviet Union that's only one example
1985 he visited Nicaragua's brutal
leader at the time Daniel Ortega why to
celebrate the sixth anniversary of the
country's socialist revolution there
Bernie called Ortega very impressive guy
even praised the country's bread lines
according to Bernie in this newly
unearthed video spending hours in line
for a chance to feed your starving
family is a good thing what take a look
you know it's funny sometimes American
journalists talk about how bad the
country is because people are lining up
for food that's a good thing other
countries people don't line up for food
the rich get the food and the poor spark
to death if you think that's bad it does
get worse nineteen eighty nine Bolshevik
Bernie well he visited communist Cuba
where he was heaping praise on the
Castro regime praising their free health
care free education free housing and
just this weekend Sanders continued to
praise Cuba's socialist dictatorship
lauding its literacy rate Wow how can
you be this disconnected take a look
very opposed to the authoritarian nature
of Cuba but you know you got it's unfair
to simply say everything is bad you know
when Fidel Castro came into office you
know what he did he had a massive
literacy program is that a bad thing
even though Fidel Castro did it a lot of
dissidents in prison didn't that's right
and we condemn that oh and there are
others murdered let me educate Vermont's
village idiot here with some hard cold
facts about the evil regime of the
Castro brothers
well that regime that burnt Bolshevik
Bernie continues to praise you might
remember they turned a cat
Caribbean paradise into a socialist
hellhole starting in the late 50s the
Republic of Cuba while they seized tens
of thousands of private farms private
homes and private businesses then they
began with Castro's political enemies
then they expanded the confiscations
nationwide and hundreds of thousands of
Cubans had to flee their home country to
the United States by the way they were
the lucky ones upwards of a hundred and
forty thousand political dissidents were
murdered by the socialist government in
Cuba
thousands more thrown in prison many
times for decades they threw away the
key today everyone in Cuba lives under
the oppressive thumb of the Castro
regime - you know Castro's gone but his
brother follows through there is no
freedom of the press there's no freedom
of speech there's no freedom of movement
it's almost impossible to get Internet
in 2015 only 5% of Cubans had access to
the Internet that is heavily censored
and according to human rights groups
surveillance beatings arbitrary
detention public acts of repudiation are
still being used by the Cuban government
and meanwhile Cuba's socialist economic
system another abject failure 1994 Cuba
facing widespread starvation leading to
an exodus of refugees 2019 the
government started rationing food Cubans
faced long lines for simple basics you
know like chicken and flour even soap
average salary in Cuba get this a
whopping $20 a month but you get free
health care meanwhile Fidel Castro well
he had an estimated net worth of around
900 million dollars but sure Congrats
Bolshevik Bernie the official literacy
rates there real high that health care
Michael Moore tells us is one to be the
envy of the world now it seems like it's
he that wants to bring that system to
the United States in other words
Bernie's talking about nationalizing
health care Medicare for all and don't
forget also they want to nationalize the
energy industry don't forget they want a
hostile takeover of all oil and gas
companies bad idea especially handing it
over to people that want to eliminate
all oil and gas which is a lifeblood of
the world's economy and frankly the
greatest economic opportunity for every
American if we tap the vast resources we
have here so
for a national-security because we don't
have to go to countries that hate our
guts and beg for the lifeblood of our
economy or get involved in foreign
entanglements over the free flow of oil
at market prices he wants free college
he wants free childcare government paid
leave green New Deal and by the way our
budget federal budget is around four and
a half trillion dollars but Bolshevik
Bernie is proposing nearly a hundred
trillion dollars in new spending over
that ten-year period hmm well somebody
get him an abacus how we gonna pay for
all these great government-run programs
well Bernie's not even sure take a look
I mean you have a price tag for all this
I mean you know and and the price tag is
it will be substantially less than
letting the current system go I think
it's about thirty trillion that's just
for Medicare for all difference you have
a price tag for all of these no why
don't we try to no you've mentioned
making public colleges and universities
tuition-free and canceling all student
debt that's correct that's what I want
to do we pay for that through a modest
tax on Wall Street speculation but you
say you don't know what the total price
is but you know how it's gonna be paid
for how do you know it's gonna be paid
for if you don't know how much the price
is marching you know I can't rattle off
your every nickel and every dime
all right polls Rubik Bernie let me help
you out you need help I'm more than
happy to buy you that abacus I'll even
get you a calculator we'll bring you up
to the Year 2022 help add up some of the
nickels and dimes you're talking about
here now I think if you want to be
President Bernie you might want to learn
some basic fundamental math ninety-three
trillion dollars for the new Green Deal
in ten years 32 trillion your estimate
Elizabeth Warren's fifty-two trillion
Medicare for all those two programs
alone cost over a hundred and twenty
trillion dollars Wow we won't take in
fifty trillion in that ten-year period
the math doesn't add up
pretty simple ultimately the only way to
fund this enormous expansion of your
government would be confiscation private
property like your friends in Cuba or
Nicaragua or the former Soviet Union
were involved in you're talking about a
wealth tax what's a wealth tax new taxes
on small business nationalizing huge
industries you're gonna take them over
Bernie's already admitted that he's
going to be raising taxes on
everyone making over $29,000 a year this
is pretty scary stuff it would devastate
our economy it would devastate
capitalism as we know it the wealth and
prosperity that we know as America the
envy of the world but at least Bolshevik
Vernie we've got to give him some credit
tonight he's being honest with some of
his counterparts are trying to hide who
they really are because in reality all
of the candidates that are running on
the Democratic side share similar ideals
every one of them buys in too much of
this nonsense in different variations
open borders eliminating what the Second
Amendment late term abortion this is
your new radical extreme socialist
Democratic Party that I have been
warning you about they all want some
version of Medicare for all some version
of the green New Deal some version of
student loan forgiveness doesn't work
retroactively Lee I paid my money back
paid family leave free housing free
medicine free medical care free healthy
food free vacations and a guaranteed
government job and none of them have any
idea how they're going to pay for any of
this and make no mistake at all all the
Democrats running for president want to
radically transform this country that
has accumulated more wealth that has
advanced the human condition more than
any other country in the history of
mankind they want the federal government
to control every aspect of your life
like Bloomberg what you can drink the
amount of salt you can put on your food
whether you want on each cigarette for
crying out loud they want to strip you
of your right to bear arms confiscate
your earnings basically after you paid
50 55 60 cents of every dollar you make
then they want another bite at the Apple
that would be called legalized stealing
and by the way even after you paid your
confiscatory taxes again if you're smart
enough to save it they'll take another
bite and then when you die they want at
least half of what you have left yet
again so they want to legalize stealing
so they can remain in power they want to
decide what you eat what you say where
you live and how you make your living
and how much you can make sounds
familiar it should because this kind of
all-powerful centralized socialist state
is government has been tried all over
the world and it has resulted every
single solitary time without exception
into nothing but suffering and carnage
for the people they promised to help so
much so it's time to send the Democratic
Party a message at the ballot box that
they're never going to forget 253 days
you're the ultimate jury you get to
shock the world again if you choose to
do so